داعش لديها العديد من المقاطع الدعائيه
لكن قادتها يفضلون الاختباء المتحدث
باسمهم محمد عدناني كشف عن خطتهم بحل حدود
سوريا والعراق دون ان يظهر وجهه وعلى
يساره قصه مغايره ابو عمر
الشيشاني فهو منفرد ويتحدث الروسيه وهو
الاقرب لان يكون زعيم العامه ضمن صفوف
داعش صعوده الطويل بين الجهاديين يعكس
خليطا معقدا من الوحش التي ادت لصعود
المجموعه فقد كان جنديا سابقا في الجيش
الجورجي وسجن لفتره وجيزه بسبب هجمات في
عام
2010 وبحسب ما قال فان السجن حوله للجهاد
ثم وصل الى سوريا وبعد عامين نقل عنه انه
كان مصدوما من مدى التحرر الذي سمح به
المعارضون حيث قال انه سمح للناس بالتدخين
وحلق اللحيه بدل اعفائها وكانوا يستمعون
الى الاغاني مضيفا ان انه راوده الشك
فالامر بدا غير مشجعا لكن سرعان ما كان
لخبرته العسكريه صدد وهو ما كان جليا في
مساعدته للسيطره على هذه القاعده التابعه
للنظام وفي معارك يكثر فيها القتل نشا ابو
عمر كرمز من خلال بقائه على قيد الحياه
وقاد مجموعه المهاجرين والانصار للانضمام
الى داعش حيث كانوا منجذبين لخطط انشاء
خلافه بحسب ما تم تناقله وانتشرت داعش
بسرعه كبيره حيث قال نشطاء انها سيطرت على
منطقه شمال شرق سوريا بخمسه اضعاف حجم
لبنان تقدم موازن لكيف اصبح جندي جرجي
سابق الرمز العلني الوحيد لزلزال متشددين
اسلاميين يكافح العالم للرد
عليه